[Music]
atlas jewel of the Pleiades
nova took us to the stars each new world
more incredible than the last
we had no idea what was waiting for us
the legion
which consumes everything in its path
they've never used StarLink before go
show them what it can do my god
chase how's it going breaking atmosphere
and the odd
judge we need to buy time for me to jump
start the engine
they are resisting ice barrage linking
fire Mona
[Music]
we're up against impossible odds but
together we will adapt
[Applause]
hi I'm Matt Rose producer at Ubisoft
Toronto like many of you I grew up in
the 80s obsessed with sci-fi animation
comics and of course all the really cool
toys at Ubisoft Toronto we built a team
with a dream of bringing those amazing
childhood memories back to life for a
new generation
Starlin battle for Atlas allows you to
take control of a team of star pilots in
a massive open living star system
fighting to save Atlas from The
Forgotten Legion build your custom
starship and then adapt to new
challenges on the fly Linc extra armor
and heavy weapons to take on a huge
Legion prime search for ancients ancient
secrets lost on the worlds of Atlas or
outrun outlaws for an asteroid field
freedom is at the core of StarLink
battle for Atlas collect your way with
both physical starship collectibles and
digital versions available and even take
your game on the go using the power of
Nintendo switch visit Starling game comm
for more information and stay tuned for
many more surprises over the coming
months thank you
[Applause]